if it's a girl she then tries to say
look through what the girl is doing see
if he commented anything under her photo
liked her photos
instagram's wack like that too cause
like it shows you you just go to
someone's uh following and the top
people are their most recent follow like
yes put that [ __ ] in alphabetical order
[Music]
[Music]
and i found that i'm a bourbon girl yeah
i i knew you started drinking when i got
a 2 am text from you saying oh my god i
just had a cannoli for the first yes
i was like low-key buzz and just like i
[ __ ] love canola yeah i know i was
like there's no way a cat's sober right
now texting me about cannolis at 2am she
has to be hammered absolutely
how
after how many years uh eight eight
years six years
yeah yeah you know
listen they're doing [ __ ] remakes to
everything and bringing all these other
things back
you know they brought friends back
didn't they
um for a reunion they're bringing back
fresh prince of bel air but making it
darker oh really it's like a drama now
oh
a drama yeah have you not seen that
preview no it looks pretty it looks it
looks good it looks like people actually
dig it uh i mean it hasn't come out or
dig the preview it looks almost like uh
i don't know i haven't seen power but
like kind of power vibe like dark
brooding it has nothing it's nothing
like the sitcom yeah the only thing that
was the same is he he had his like uh
uniform yeah jacket that he wore inside
out yeah i know that was i actually
thought that was so cool and i never
realized it was inside out
for like the longest time no i didn't
know i was like why the [ __ ] is his so
different and then come to find out it's
inside out so i'm gonna start doing that
with everything now
play that trailer
wait have you seen the show the proud
family before on disney channel
the proud boy family
that's different that's different family
uh yeah i remember proud family yeah so
i didn't know that the gross sisters
were blue because they were ashy and
yeah
beyonce yes solange the one that was
no she was singing in the uh theme song
intro with destiny's child oh really
yeah when she was a kid i didn't know
that wait when the [ __ ] did proud family
come out
early 2000s i want to say really yeah
probably two maybe even two thousand
yeah
it was kind of just as i was like
stopping watching 2001
came out 2001
so then i too in 2001
i was 14.
you know what else happened in 2001
what
yeah september 11th right
i thought this was going to be something
in your life personally no no no no well
that was personally in my life yeah i
cut off your intro of you telling
everybody what the hell we're doing here
oh i did i i cut off your intro oh we're
doing a ruby oh well we're bringing it
back [ __ ] cats after dark baby guys
are back yeah we're the crew but this
time it's gonna be
uh you don't have to pay for it yeah
this is something we're gonna do for
free it's podcasting which you all love
and uh we love this cruise the solid
crew and it'll be on the thick boy
network channel zip away network channel
and then the second second half so yeah
to the sick boy super cast
so you're about to pay if you want to
get the last end of it yeah we're gonna
put like juicy [ __ ] behind it
yeah we can get juicy with that at the
half of it let us know when we're at the
halfway mark we'll get we'll get it real
juicy right should we have like a theme
song or like a this is
gonna
say like to the fans out there we're
kind of starting from scratch and it's
uh it's a low budget show meaning
there's a it's a no budget show yeah
uh eddie supernova do you want to
contribute like a logo
theme song send that [ __ ] in yeah send
it all in cats after dark gmail.com yeah
yeah we're all freelancing at the moment
and then we got a cool guy kyle
and a [ __ ] dork
fat ass up by the way they play with
each other like that they're not really
i don't know it's like
wait wait you said they play with each
other yeah i know right yeah
with each other pause
the phrase was bad but they like to mess
around
with each other we really hate each
other so you know what one time and i
blocked that [ __ ] too one time
someone messaged me yo you [ __ ] mean
the meatball man you're such a [ __ ]
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
i know
it wasn't your burner account
can i tell you a story about the first
conversation i had with christian when
he started working with brendan it was
through his burner account no it wasn't
fired no no no
well maybe but after the cap when it's
on super cast we'll talk about that
so i started talking to christian once
he got onboarded and i was giving him
all of the credentials all of the social
media passwords and for some reason he
couldn't log into i think the king
listing account or the or brennan's
account he couldn't log in for some
reason and for days he was kind of
looking around like i don't know what it
is i'm putting in the right passwords
and then he tells me oh i have too many
burner accounts on i need to log out of
some of them in order to add an account
on here i was like how many burner
accounts are you
um
i had the fighter and the kid i had my
so when i got banned from tick tock i
made a new instagram account to post all
my [ __ ] on there yes uh and then i had
just yo let it go
yeah maybe it's not
like this guy not [ __ ] that i don't know
i don't give up dog but also thank you
for your honesty because so many people
use burner accounts but they won't admit
to it oh i know how many people live
but they won't admit it yeah i didn't
realize that yeah and all my friends
started telling me i got a burner for
what i know i don't get it i don't know
why see i use it just to talk [ __ ] and
not get in trouble especially when i
first started with fighting the kid i
knew i couldn't use my account so i just
did it to talk [ __ ] um and i just do it
to like like
uh check up on people i don't want to
know i'm checking up on so it's like
anonymous girls do that all the time
explain that again you don't want them
to know you want to do anonymously you
don't want people to know you follow
them
oh my god okay okay my burner account
you will not be able to correlate oh so
like if it's a private account until now
you use your burner to follow they don't
know first of all who's accepting burner
accounts as a like if you're in public
you're good yeah if you're public you're
good but if the person's but if you're
public why don't you just use your
regular account to [ __ ] see what
they're doing because then they see that
you check up on it like the stories okay
so stories yeah it's like stories and
then also lurking on other people's
accounts because i have a girlfriend who
has terrible trust issues where every
single time she dates a guy she goes
through this period after
they are kind of like rocky where she
wants to see what he's doing who he's
following if he goes out on a night and
she sees like his follower count went up
by like one or two she then goes on her
burner looks through everybody that he's
following who's following him to see who
the new person is if it's a girl she
then tries to say look through what the
girl is doing see if he commented
anything under her photo liked her
photos
instagram's wack like that too because
like it shows you
you just go to someone's uh following
and the top people are their most recent
follow like yes put that [ __ ] in
alphabetical order
but also like what's so [ __ ] crazy is
like don't be in a relationship
that's [ __ ] crazy the world isn't
that simple well i mean like that's why
like my relationship is so [ __ ]
boring to people because like literally
it's a great relationship what i love
your relationship with you i mean i i
yeah i know that but like it's an adult
relationship it's not yeah it's
like why do people make that so [ __ ]
difficult like honestly instead of like
having a [ __ ] burner to go through to
see what the [ __ ] they're doing why
don't you just ask them who they are i
don't know huh
like is it right am i crazy yes
yo eat a dick well there are also
situations where people won't tell you
in the nicest way yeah you know what i
mean yeah what were you saying there are
situations where people won't tell you
the truth either
if you know that then don't be with the
[ __ ] yes absolutely that's how i
feel because it's like if i if i don't
trust this person
and whatever blah blah blah then why
would i be with the [ __ ] if i
know they're getting down on the down
low or whatever i mean but also [ __ ]
like my my girlfriend's asked me about
all the girls in my life obviously
yeah very honest like i'm like yeah
[ __ ] yeah i know this [ __ ] girl
that cheered with her blah blah blah but
also i told her the girl that i chew
with her yeah there's so there's so many
they're so they're so [ __ ] many but
also but like but like at the same time
like i'm like yo it would have already
happened yeah that's why i tell that
girl it would already have it now she is
funny because the girl she guesses that
she thinks i slept with she's way off
and the ones that she would never guess
like she's just [ __ ] yeah she's never
guessing oh so yeah so way off she's
looking at all the hot ones like no it's
yeah yeah no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no listen
[Laughter]
[ __ ] why you searching me
other girls huh you say is there all the
other girls that she has to worry about
no not really look at they're on my
profile
all right
who the [ __ ] first of all who made that
yeah
it's on
full-time comedian part-time
who made that gymnastic [ __ ] that you do
i watched some videos oh dude here pause
that you like pause that pause that
first of all first of all listen i will
cut that i don't [ __ ] those dudes
i [ __ ] mean that because i did their
[ __ ] second half [ __ ] yeah this one
second second half [ __ ] we can move it
those [ __ ] i went and did their
[ __ ] podcast right
and it was a good podcast it was chill
right i had a good time with it then
when they dropped the [ __ ] episode
they decorate they they the the title of
the [ __ ] episode was chappelle lacy
la comedy is dying
and i was like what the [ __ ] i called
dude up i said hey what are you doing
he's like what i said you can't just
[ __ ] put that like i got like
no i made it i bullied them all right
yeah i've made those [ __ ] stains
changing come on now stop playing uh
but uh but anyways did was that any of
the discussion or was it like i'm sure
it was like it just came out they were
like hey your episode dropped here's
here it is and i saw the title and it
said chappelle ac la comedy is dying and
i was like so it's click bait yeah and i
was like yo i was like don't do that i
was like i was like i'm not the deciding
factor of la comics diet and i was like
first of all i never said that in the
episode i was like don't do that you
know like they're like oh sorry you know
our producer just swings from the hip
then they try to word it another way but
it still was basically la comedy
dead or whatever now you're like very
salacious yeah and i'm like hey stop i
was like i was like that's not good at
all just put chappelle lacy la comedian
i was like just title it that but i was
i was really [ __ ] heated listen
they're probably nice guys or whatever
blah blah blah but at the same time it's
like yo that's my [ __ ] name
you know what i mean it's like you're
not just gonna [ __ ]
put that kind of stuff out like like
it's it's dumb you know like you you
don't know what that does like you know
what that that does for me that stirs up
[ __ ] because there are because like and
at the time i did that podcast i only
been living in la for two years i was
like what do i know about like there's
people that have been here way longer
than i have what the [ __ ] do i know i
was like you can't do that and i know i
was aggressive calling them [ __ ] stains
earlier but i didn't mean that not [ __ ]
but that was just very aggressive and it
was just coming out of me but like
needless to say like i did enjoy doing
their podcast and i thought we had a
great great great conversation
but
it's just a title like you just can't do
that you know what i mean like i don't
know i don't agree with that kind of
click bait type of stuff and i'm
assuming that show isn't i've never
recognized
recognized them that's not very popular
like so you're already doing a favor
just by going on there but then they
have to try to manipulate it more by
like yeah
which kind of bummed me out you know
because it's like if i gave you the time
my day like like you i would expect you
to treat it
you know with respect and i felt like i
was just disrespected right there you
know what i mean it is hard to get away
from those click bait headlines yeah
don't don't show that one though i don't
you're blurred out yeah they'll show
that
i just want to see how many like how big
they were were right now they were right
they only know only sixty one thousand
that's nothing again that's just their
clip saying yeah
six one thousand seven
all right we came out of the gate with
sixty one thousand on this i'd be stoked
no no that's just subscribers in general
but that's that's actually
that's so funny about tick tock though
like how like
how how aggressive it is when it comes
to like
restriction but you were showing your
balls yeah you know what's crazy
you and you
and you you probably had already seen my
balls at this point but before i met you
three you guys had seen my balls before
i met you i still haven't seen him and i
do not yeah i'll show you right now yeah
no
i'm okay second half second half
[Laughter]
just wait for it wait for it to win the
thick boy super cast to see me show my
boss to kyle no no we don't need to see
your [ __ ] balls jim you you're more
you've probably been on the platform is
there a way to like uh do promo codes on
uh super cast so you could give someone
like a discount for a month and then we
could see how many people were driving
since they're
they're relatively new i'm sure we can
and we it's a very small team and we're
we're always talking to him so we could
probably create that that'd be dope
yeah
then he could find out from all the
shows where they're coming from and [ __ ]
and then you can
ask for money
for his balls hey what's everyone been
up to stop playing yeah stop playing i
want to hear more i want to hear about
the race from your perspective the race
from my perspective yeah i i i heard uh
the race
okay
the race from my perspective yeah you
know i just know i just didn't stop
running
i kept running and running and running
false start that's what oh yeah yeah
yeah so yeah that was that's what
happened the false start no one caught
it you did i caught it but i was like
it's already happening but then you're
right then we had to stop it yeah yeah
so we did have a false start and that
initial
push i think is when he he pulled up
yeah he [ __ ] up one of his hamstrings
you know what i mean and then
it uh
and then we i said i said dude i was
like we don't [ __ ] i was like we
don't have to do this at all
huh yeah you were standing right there i
was like dude we don't have i was like
what we have nothing to [ __ ] prove
who's that that you i had 20 bucks oh
you cheered me on yeah i had 20 bucks
that's the thing christian is low-key
your biggest cheerleader wow yeah that's
a super bold move to be cheering against
out loud the guy who pays you i know
yeah
that's just tearing both hamstrings
that's a bold move
[Laughter]
because that day kyle was recording some
stuff and then casey was recording casey
came to me with a camera and i said oh
i'm rooting for brendan because he gave
me a career meanwhile christian is like
oh i have chappelle all the way no it's
so funny which i accepted that everybody
was with brendan hey be with him be with
him nobody but you're confident we're
betting on
even outside of the workplace i i posted
a poll and it was close it was 58
brendan 46 you listen i didn't think it
was not a challenge that went [ __ ]
fast but that's the thing you're all so
fast you are the one person who's always
like oh yeah like whatever like you kind
of let up you're like okay you're not
that confident in something that you say
but when you know your [ __ ] you're like
yes yeah i know something was
yeah because people don't give me credit
because of the cheerleading they just
don't think i'm not going to give you
more credit they'll give you more credit
because because it's true because it's
not athletic oh no they do not give me
any other [ __ ] really yes they don't
consider you an athlete hell no
do they see what you listen it doesn't
it doesn't listen it doesn't bug me at
all because most of those [ __ ]
i can beat their ass you know what i
mean i'm like oh i don't know but yeah
what are you gonna [ __ ] what do you
gotta do to me huh anyways but uh no a
lot of people discredit it because they
don't know about it yeah that's the only
thing so that's why i don't get mad it's
like oh you don't know you don't know
what i did
you know what i mean what were you gonna
say i said i i actually took into
account that you were a cheerleader as a
reason for me to uh think you were to
win because the amount of explosivity
you have to have to be able to do all
those [ __ ] backs uh
meanwhile you made a tick tock making
fun of cheerleaders again before i knew
you
[Laughter]
let's pull that off
all right oh you have it uh yeah it
should be on my instagram
you know how many people tagged me in
that dude wanted me to hate you i had
the worse anxiety because my first day i
like i mean i'm like all right like i
gotta make a good impression after the
first day awesome my instagram blows up
chappelle's chipotle chappelle says like
oh this guy's gonna [ __ ] hate me no i
don't care you know what's so funny
about when anyone new comes to anything
the amount of [ __ ] [ __ ] talking
people will deliver to you and it's like
hey i just accepted a [ __ ] position
you know what i mean
like
the amount of [ __ ] you got yeah it was
like well i just accepted i said yes
that was all like
you were presented with a job
opportunity times article about brian
second part second half second half
is that what they're thinking like are
we starting rumors off the jump yeah
yeah that's so [ __ ] funny did uh do
you have a message on your computer yeah
uh i texted it to you too did it come up
what are you still pulling up the
cheerleader thing i'm doing both both
but uh on king and it's funny we did a
cat's after dark and
the week before we had uh we did a
debate club who's who do you think's
gonna win in the race uh you were you
were brendan and
cr eric picked you
chris picked brendan
uh and then the next week someone sent
in this cats after dark
and uh
i was like someone said this is
hilarious
chappelle wasn't too happy with chris
like how all of us knew who those two
people oh yeah immediately i was like oh
that's dalia
yeah let's see this [ __ ] yeah people
tagged me in this damn tick tock
so much scroll down you know where your
[ __ ] is christian your picture with
these i know what the hell you got to
get him more conversational just
standing by him spoiling act like you're
like talking
about
like look at him signature
let him live
i mean i i
he could even spit it out you know where
it's at right there to the left
[ __ ] i'm a big gangster i turn around
with this foreign law that's a
cheerleader one yes
but look how many times i'm tagged
it's just nothing about you
i got a lot of heat for that i don't
know why
i don't get it so i don't get it either
it's a trend like where someone says
something they do and then like you're
on facetime with them and like they're
like oh i'm a chew lyric oh and you hang
up but were you facetiming a dude
because why would you hang up on a girl
cheerleader because that's cool because
i said what's traditionally hot i was
saying what sport do you play and they
said i cheerleader i was making a joke
like that cheerleading's not a sport got
you because it's not so you just [ __ ]
you don't excuse me what do you consider
it then yeah what do you consider an
activity an activity an activity like
you have to be extreme
before but now you do after you see all
this no i think you think he still
doesn't consider us an actor after
seeing chapel
who's a better athlete you and me what
you did
no
no all of it what you did that's a sport
in this i was referencing like high
school cheerleading like oh my god oh my
god
that's all right hey that's actually
legit cheerleading the [ __ ] you did i
will never be able to do that type of
[ __ ] all right there you go
i like i like the way you backpedal i
like the way
i like the back pedal specific it's very
specific yeah very specific you know so
i don't know let me break it down and
break down you know okay that's it hey
listen yeah i'm kind of glad that they
commented you in that a lot that
definitely helped my traffic to that
video though
yeah yeah everyone kept telling me like
i was gonna beat you up
well you still could i still could
really you're not gonna
think you could beat me up
after this oh wrong button yeah yeah you
can't even keep [ __ ] right of course i
can kick you learning though oh
okay
i was really surprised man i gave him so
much props
600 they lift you up like
and they just hey i mean listen i just
i've [ __ ] deadlifted 500 pounds that
day
i'm just saying the fact that they can
lift you up easily
excuses yeah
they're strong they're very strong yeah
i give it i give you problems together
you couldn't get your strong
i'm stronger that's the thing
how's your neck doing though that sucks
yeah at least i want that surprised his
neck that's when that happened it was
hard
the neck thing happened like weeks later
but there was another one wasn't it
people were saying that
here's the thing i'm an adult like if
i'm going to get into like a thing it's
it's my decision so yeah okay i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah i don't think it's time
because when i went to the doctor
they're like there's like degradation
over time so it's eventually what's
going to happen and like two of my
closest friends they have the same issue
because they're on computers all the
time so be careful about your posture i
don't think those things helped your
situation no definitely i think they
definitely added to it i wouldn't say it
was the only reason why but it was
definitely i do feel like it was gonna
happen regardless especially my posture
and now because of that i i'm way better
about taking care of my body working out
exercising
doing the attraction stuff as well i
tell you i tell you one thing
after this [ __ ] thick mutter
i will never do anything like that ever
again wow you haven't even done it yet
what have you done i i know how i feel
yeah you you didn't you haven't done it
yet not yet because have you uh no but
like
from people i don't know it sounds like
it's not that bad it's only five miles
right now is it ten yeah
a lot different but going into it i'm
like 10 [ __ ] miles what do you want
me to do what do you want me to do for
10 miles okay six point four miles so no
it's it's 15k oh 15k 15k is 10 point
something miles or whatever 9.6 miles
9.6 or yeah 9.2 so basically 10 miles in
some
yeah like you like dropped your weight
look right here
[Laughter]
yeah that's what he did you got you got
dragged out into the door
second wisconsin second half the second
half second half seconds
still not allowed
come on after all the success yeah i
haven't been back for a while but
literally like
five years later they recognized me and
they're like no you gotta go
it was like damn
maybe four i was like 90 when it
happened or 21 obviously and then like
maybe it was like two years later but
like same management and but if they
know you now
well who you are now they'd be like oh
[ __ ] nick no they're like
you don't want the ire of the 4 000
people to watch my instagram story who
most likely don't live in minneapolis
you don't want that
this bar
it was my favorite bar too burrito loco
they had this
uh they had like a different really
awesome special every night one night
was a flip a coin night yeah you could
order any drink you wanted and you
flipped a coin if you got it right it
was free so it's basically fifty percent
off yeah like i went six for six one
night oh damn
definitely not the night ago
like that was probably yeah that bar was
sweet there it is and then they had
burritos on the bottom
yeah that looks like a dangerous place
for me
just like a perfect dive bar
little bag of the day dark corner for
you a little dark corner yeah that's a
real dark sound i said where i used to
go man i used to go to this
bar back home called crescent ballroom
and i used to sit at the [ __ ] bar
by myself yourself i remember this and i
was oh you remember yeah and i would
watch that [ __ ] what's her name dr
ruth yeah the lady that talks about all
the sex toys
all the sex [ __ ] yeah yeah i would sit
there and watch that and just drink by
my [ __ ] self dope spot also a concert
venue that's it as well yep go to images
it matches
was it dr ruth or was it the su
which whichever one talks about sex toys
they both they both do and they're both
old but like
susan or something look up like sex
therapist susan yeah they're like 62.
and it wasn't mesa arizona that was
phoenix yeah
uh
susan
oh she's bad susan's a sexy lady
yeah that's not her
it was an older lady there yo speaking
of random blonde white ladies did you
see that thing with the with the cop
yeah uh she
they let her go well they gave her 30k
to quit because she started she had an
only fans
um
you just see that i don't know oh my god
type it wait is that her though that's
not the route no that's that's the that
i would want to watch
okay there you go in the latest
knowledge she must have type in uh cop
typing cop starts only fans or something
like that so they paid for so much
knowledge they paid in their league
joe hanson johansen johansen dr ruth has
to be your free there's a there's two
types of people in this world people who
learn sex from dr ruth and people who
learn sex from uh johansen yeah i was
learned sex from actually having sex
it was a bit that those no it was it was
a person
identical to dr ruth
what that's the same word that's dr ruth
that's doctor rooney what up mark
some of these people are what up mark
what up mark stop playing
are you voting yeah yeah yeah dude mark
can just smell when it comes on very
chill
mark mark gets like a tingling sensation
whenever someone's recording something
when a camera's on
come on in
yeah we always got camera time for you
but anyways type in cop starts only fans
and they're probably trying to pay her
out because they don't have any legal
grounds to fire her correct is that
whether yeah
um
no no no no no far right kyla
spots with mark yeah
those uh welcome our first guest to our
first guest hella mark harley actually a
returning guest from the original
iteration go to hey go to images again
christian
say please [ __ ] yeah i would
have loved you
top far right
the most educated
it's nice to hear that sentiment because
um
i do hope to pass something on to people
you know and stevie was a great like
interviewer in the sense that he knows
nothing about diet nutrition so i'm
explaining all the basics and i'm going
to be honest with you
the only reason i watched at first is
because you you got more views than my
episode of stephen
this is view king right here i was all
stoked yeah i beat chappelle
and then you and then you left me this
is view king where where's your sitting
at uh it's like thirty one thousand
we're all very nothing next so if you
guys want to go support
hold on no go michelle yeah
can't beat everybody oh yeah i know oh
that's what you were that's what you
were fishing for oh what are you doing
no i genuinely wanted to know because i
have 31 i think but yeah what was yours
uh yeah i think last time i checked with
60. yeah i see mine what was yours i
think
hey we better go back to that lady i was
looking up yeah that only fans the only
fans girl the our
i looked at it for spite and then i
really learned a lot i'm glad that that
worked out i love that everything that
drives you is spite me
i love it you thrive off of negativity
but how cool is stevie for having us all
on his show too i [ __ ] love stevie
i went on a bad friends i did bad
friends oh snap yeah but i told stevie
weeby on his show that the like i was a
super fan of him because the first
podcast i ever watched was dvd asa
before i knew what a podcast was this
was uh asa akira david cho
and stevie weavey was there as well
i was telling him that i'm the biggest
like stevie weeby fan from back in the
day like before i did any podcast like i
love him
colin yeah it's hannah baron
that's our girl oh [ __ ] it is an ad
yeah i think she does a lot of sponsored
posts for this company hey can we go
back to that girl like that officer i'm
just talking about with the only fans
we're on it
you liar
there she is
hey type in images see what the see
what's the pictures
that's okay so i don't want to be
missing probably
i will say that you can make a lot of
money on only fans if you have the right
niche audience it's not about oh
necessarily
yeah because there might be a lot of
people who are like oh even if it's not
necessarily like me trying to jack off
to your content i want to support a cop
hey login to your eight years old sure
christian log into your only fans
account and see if you can find her i
don't have one actually flies i don't
um
after i paid for cats i was like all
right i'm done
[ __ ] you
but yeah who else has a only fans rachel
dolezal
remember when she came out
see workout videos oh
that's her okay this is like interesting
now that's the officer
oh nice
i wa see it always kind of bums me out
when people type in only fans pictures
work in those type of jobs like you need
to do
let's see what she do on the only fans
dawg that's why i didn't type in only
facebook go to the right go to the right
mark right not about an uh no f
no no no no no
right there really yeah the blue um
before yeah she probably kills it now
that everybody knows i don't think i
could do that unless i was already in a
safe position of like it's just i mean
like as a guy
i know guys who make
bank on only things you're showing their
weinus or like some guys only will do
applied content no like straight up like
naked and then like covering everything
yeah and they make a [ __ ] killing um
would you though mark i will say there
is a market for it the first thing that
comes to my mind is um
like what if i put it up and nobody
subscribes
you just need to get your account out
there trust me people will find you and
like eat you up i'm telling you yeah i
just
the there there is a would be a gay
stigma for me like not that i care to
have but it's like
do i want like another angle of attack
from haters to be like oh he's like
you're just showing his dick on anything
like i would you know if that was a
viable way to make money for me but it's
just you know again what i'm also saying
disney show
nickelodeon oh so that's going to be
fair i thought when you said a cop was
on only fans that it was going to be the
one that got did the lap dance around
christmas time at the holiday party i
did too i was kind of hoping for that
she looked up she looked hot she should
have she's did we talk about that
remember on king and the sting we did
for sure but uh i mean she was like some
lieutenant and she gave her sergeant a
lap dance he was married so that was
like another controversy right but yeah
i mean they were just getting crazy at a
work party you have a clip of it yeah
if you just actually just searched uh
new york holiday party oh there it is oh
wow christian knows what's going on
at wild holiday
what does she look like
just out of curiosity i think
she actually looked cute i think you
can't tell from there that she's hot no
no i i mean i i'd like to see your face
her body the guy that wants to know the
girl's entire personality before he
determines if she's hot that is very
true i love that yeah
that's not something that's not like a
bad thing no
no it's not
cat
then i want no personality listen uh
vera maculey vera macule rare macule
that's very peculiar
walmart that's my lane
[Laughter]
shitty puns on this show
[Laughter]
but mark if you're thinking about doing
only fans talk to me afterwards i'll run
some numbers
with you trust me like it i know certain
guys who make x amount of money yeah no
that would be interesting because i just
never considered it but but i think
doing any sort of exclusive content
whether or not you know like when i
think of what a guy would do on there
yeah type it in or i assume he's jerking
out but then you know okay i'll say this
i look at what tyga's done which is like
create his own like porno channel where
he's [ __ ] a bunch of girls like now
that sounds cool to me like no but you
know that's her
if that's her she's definitely
especially for a cop she's all right
calm down chris leave me especially for
a cop oh i mean because you don't expect
cops to be that hot you know she's got a
verified instagram now oh
oh it's an evil eye i wonder if it's
actually her you're gonna message her
man no
i already did [ __ ]
you did oh christian who are you what
did it say what is it it says arrest me
[Laughter]
you shoot your [ __ ] shots
he's trying to shoot threes all the time
i respect that dm
does anybody know what time we started i
don't uh i didn't catch it hour 20 is
pretty long but once you get a groove it
goes faster but i think we've been going
in about 25 minutes
yeah
i don't know you've been going all over
the world it seems like uh cat yeah
we are looking oh nice oh look at that
yeah let's go to that general tab there
christian
[Laughter]
oh my god
yo
the best thing that apple has ever done
i don't know if you guys know this but
so apple made an update so say i text
someone i can highlight the text and
then translate it to another language
that's where apple [ __ ] up because
after that i just started going on the
explore page in like germany berlin and
i was just dm'ing girls for like a solid
week in just german i had no idea what
the [ __ ] i was saying like i was trying
to use google translate before that wait
no you can type so like on my phone
instead of going typing and then going
to google translate no they have they
have different keyboards like i have a
vietnamese keyboard in mine
quicker yeah
so you have to know what you're saying
for it to translate over like you have
to know what you use google translate
you just copy and paste i don't even
have to do that now all i have to do is
type in what i want to say
hold down on it and then translate it
together wait wait wait wait wait when
you hold down on it all these like
languages pop up
uh select few like
languages all these languages have you
dm so many girls you have to start going
internationally i know i know right yeah
yeah
the dating pool isn't big enough in this
yeah no yeah also what are you gonna do
because
are you gonna go there
yeah if i find it one bad enough because
we were we were watching a show called
bear town it's about like a swedish show
like we were on a cake like where we
would just watch foreign shows and the
girls in that show
are so gorgeous i was like i need to get
a girl that barely speaks english like i
just couldn't help it so i just started
doing it you need to get a girl that
barely speaks yes bring her over to the
u.s she can use me for a green card i'm
okay with that
[Laughter]
like one of the things
because
uh
i do relate to that like you know you
see pot girls internationally
one of the things that i have thought
about over the past few years is the
the even just the cultural barrier it's
really cool to be in a relationship with
somebody where you like reference things
in american culture that they get it can
be
annoying to explain things to people who
come from another country and like it's
no fault of their own obviously yeah
like even a slight language barrier and
a slight cultural barrier can sometimes
be really like oh my [ __ ] god like i
have to know
he-man was this show in the 80s
a lot of girls just because i'm i'm
[ __ ] weird with references and [ __ ]
right
now you realize how important it is to
have the same cultural lexicon yeah when
that's missing like it throws it off in
a way that you don't like it's you don't
necessarily anticipate that when you
think about like oh this [ __ ]
beautiful italian girl whatever um
you know i'm not saying don't ever do
that but it's just something to think
about kristen like what do you like
do you want it like do you want a
relationship or are you just trying to
[ __ ] i'm just trying to [ __ ] i don't
have a spot to say like when i visit
those countries but i'm i'm down to like
settle down in like later on in life but
i'm 23 i don't want a long-term
relationship yeah unless
i'm always shocked by the people that
are like yeah man you know me and my
[ __ ] lady been together for like 10
years and they're like 23 and i'm like
what the [ __ ] oh that was me yeah that
was you that was me i was with my
ex-boyfriend from
like 14 15 to 23. oh damn were you guys
gonna get married uh yeah i was actually
secretly engaged and i didn't tell
anybody
what no he was filipino filipino yeah he
and i were engaged what since i was in
college i just never told anybody this
is the first time you're saying it uh to
like a camera yes was there a reason you
didn't what was his name i don't look
like i know right yeah
you're the only [ __ ] weirdo that
would do some [ __ ] like that bro you he
i didn't know you had a girlfriend for
the longest time because you hide her
you don't want to go what do you want me
to say really let's go no he's different
he's private but he's it's not a secret
so first
listen you want to know why because what
the [ __ ] does it matter
yeah why why why does it matter because
you're not hiding the fact that you have
a girlfriend i'm not hiding in fact
but it's just like why why can't i just
have that to myself yes like everything
else like is out there about me why
can't i [ __ ] have my own relationship
to myself yeah right because if you post
the person where you're also opening up
them up to scrutiny yeah exactly like
you're like
i don't want
why does it matter you know like and
people think i'm crazy because i because
i feel that way but it's like literally
like why the [ __ ] yo get the [ __ ] off my
instagram
anyways hey you know what else is cool
is it but
your girl doesn't your girl doesn't
demand that of you either no you make
her feel confident enough about your
relationship which is
like that's what i'm saying like that
like when people are like i don't know
someone's tried to search my name and or
my friend my friends try to search my
name on google because they just want to
see like what the [ __ ] google says about
terrible which also annoys the [ __ ] out
of me too i go listen quit doing [ __ ]
but but one of the top searches is
chappelle lacy's girlfriend
that's one of the top searches when you
certainly learn yeah it's like well okay
women women
[Laughter]
do you guys know that chappelle gets
dm'd constantly by women specifically
saying you're handsome oh yeah i don't
get that like none of my friends get it
like i'm you know there's some online
flirtation river but like
chappelle has sent me so many
screenshots of girls saying the same
thing which is
you're handsome you're so handsome and
you know why that is because because
he's a genuinely nice guy there's a
difference between men who say oh nice
guys finish lost i'm a nice guy girls
don't like me yeah that's a manipulative
very interesting that's like
he's like a genuinely nice guy and girls
can see that like yeah you're one of
those guys where i'm around you and i
know like i am safe in this vicinity i
don't have to expect any sort of
[ __ ]
a female comic said to me and that's
very exciting i love being around you
because i know you're not trying to [ __ ]
me no but that is like no goes it goes a
long way you can be both like nice and
like the reason nice gets associated
with uh not doing well with women
because it also as you said the
manipulation aspect you're a
manipulative [ __ ] if you say you're
i think the thing is like guys that say
that [ __ ] like oh you know girls don't
like me because i'm too nice and it's
like no that's not it like it's like
like you could be [ __ ] nice but
there's got to be more to you yeah you
know there's all there's so much to it
because i used to be that dude i would
say [ __ ] like that but i was also in
[ __ ] junior high when i would say it
you know what i mean like yeah but but
like when i hear dudes say it as an
adult like i'm like oh what are you
talking about because they they're
saying it as though like being nice they
are then entitled to something yeah
you're entitled to something and you're
not because you're a nice guy and it's
like no you're not entitled to anything
nice your way and that's what that's
what you mean by genuinely yeah like
you're genuinely a good guy and that
like shows throughout like the camera in
person listen even though i get
aggressive with meatball all the [ __ ]
time listen that's just our [ __ ] time
that's just our [ __ ] you know i may talk
i may speak aggressively but like
you know that's that's just i mean
that's just never trying to take
advantage i'm not trying to take
advantage of anybody i don't care like
even even when i was talking about that
podcast i did earlier they were [ __ ]
great guys you know they like it like i
had the time of my life actually having
a great conversation with two
two [ __ ] people that i did not
[ __ ] know i was just being aggressive
lacey you know sometimes sometimes that
[ __ ] pops out you know what i'm saying
it's not always man
it's not always managed but you know
what hey you're trying i'm trying day by
day step by step i think we can call
this the halfway point uh so use promo
code dark on on super cast
we won't post unless it happens i don't
cut it out if it doesn't work uh so
we'll go the second half in the second
half we're gonna look at christian's dms
his wiener we're gonna look at
chappelle's girlfriend go check that out
i really want to make like an
inspirational quote page of you can't
like it's you it's dark it's brooding
and it says you can't nice your way into
some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you just said earlier i started with s
when he was we were explaining that like
nice guys simp
oh [ __ ] no i have a like
oh is that another one that's one of my
favorite topics in general is the
difference like i mean just
understanding a lot of guys don't
understand this is why they get confused
like
the shorthand for this is alpha beta
right like but i like to go okay that's
kind of an overused word and so you look
at these specific qualities that you'd
have as a man that women find attractive
or unattractive right and so
niceness often correlates with like
neediness
non-edginess uh inability to to take a
stand or have an opinion right if you're
so nice like a
a pushover yeah that's really what is
important
if a girl senses that you're going to
change your opinion to whatever hers is
she's like ugh right yeah if a guy can
just be confident and like you can be
calm confident and nice and still have
that kind of alpha energy of like oh i
know if [ __ ] went down this guy would
spring into action or just isn't afraid
to say no or set a boundary all those
things are real yeah it's not like being
nicer
mark's been mark's been reading some
[ __ ] or
not reading or like finding these like
[ __ ] interesting videos where this
girl talks about like
toxic masculinity but she talks about it
in a way where she like breaks it down
to where
you told me about it yeah
you were gonna send me some [ __ ] but
basically it's like a female that's like
like
like breaking it down to where other
females understand because a lot of
females will go after like these dudes
that are like this bro culture or
whatever blah blah blah
you know what i'm talking about she's a
brunette girl yeah courtney ryan i think
is her youtube channel yeah yeah yeah
she's like dating advice for men yes and
it's really good like you know and some
people say you can't get dating advice
from girls because you know a fisherman
doesn't ask a fish how to catch fish uh
but
i
she has really good pointers she has
really good style tips like it's just a
good youtube channel channel in general
but i like a lot of this stuff because
like in that world of
if you're a guy going asking the
question how can i date more women
really what you're asking is how do i be
the best version of myself and like
communicate to people better so there's
all these correlated things that you can
improve
rather than just treating like a a very
narrow like pickup artistry like
technique like because you know you
could learn certain lines or tactics to
get women's attention but
the real way to do it to become more
attractive to to women is to improve
yourself and be the best version of
yourself and
understand what masculinity means and
try to uh work towards being more
masculine she's a guy
i can't remember if
because i'm probably [ __ ] butchering
it so bad but was was it her that was
like kind of
going against the word toxic
it's very possible because i do think
that's an overused word like there are
instances where it's appropriate but
today we sort of conflate
any masculinity with toxic mastery it's
almost redundant the way people are wait
wait what do you mean like they'll say
any sign of masculinity you know like
like stoicism assertiveness
aggressiveness competitiveness
right all these things that you sort of
like like being being non-reactive being
decisive being strong like any
indication of masculinity or like a
traditional
masculine social role
somebody out there is going to go well
that's just toxic masculinity like
really yeah and masculinity is
he's using stoicism as in the emotional
way of not showing your emotions not the
philosophical like yeah because i'm like
there's so much to it because i i mean
he literally we like we like winked at
each other about ryan holiday because we
i don't know stoicism is like [ __ ]
huge right now it's it's it's like i
hold it [ __ ] near and dear to my
heart yeah was that weed huh yeah can i
have something yeah
[Laughter]
59 minute mark yeah we kind of switch
it's going to be it's going to be kind
of a rough transition but i i said it
mark
yeah it's all the same stuff and it's
really interesting because again
there's that's one way into it and like
i think the the principles and just
having an awareness of like
if you're a guy what what's like a
formula like for example the mystery
method is like
oh yeah attraction um rapport and
seduction is like the three stages of
whatever not like you can just look at
it and have a blueprint but it's like
i just think men need a better like
awareness of like what is the woman
experiencing as you're trying to [ __ ]
her
you know yeah
because it just i think it increases
your you know although people can use
these lay their techniques and can use
it
in an exploitative way i just think as a
guy you should both be learning to talk
to women effectively like learn how to
turn them on learn how to like learn how
to be good in bed learn how to look
better and be in better shape and dress
better and [ __ ] be more successful go
after what you want because ultimately
those are all things that are going to
like make you more attractive give you
better relationships all these things i
know for sure i believe that because
much more than just getting majority of
the girls that i questioned
majority
of the majority of the girls that have
my question
majority of you know the girls that i've
slept with in life like i'm actually
still cool with yeah you know yeah cause
you didn't have to fly your way into
some [ __ ] yeah like it was it was like
but like that was a thing it happened
yeah you know but also at the same time
like
i don't know
i don't explain it to where it just how
it just organically just kept being like
eventually just evolved into
a friendship i'm the same way you know
what i mean to where it's just like i
don't know this
she's a nice person you know what i mean
like that's what
yeah that's what i don't know why you
slept with in the first place what'd you
say i said that's why you slept with her
in the future oh yeah i mean i'm
evidently makes your way to some dick
it's true girls can when you meet a girl
you're like you're really nice like you
can get some dick dude
listen like we're we're getting this is
the second half yeah yeah yo i used to
get um
and i hate i hate it because i i don't
want to seem like it's like a bragging
thing but i wasn't i wasn't a [ __ ]
guy
that and i've never been able to you
know to where i would just like hound
for it
but like there was a point time where
girls just like
needed to like have sex with me and
that's all they wanted from me they
wanted nothing else what was that time
period oh [ __ ] this is like 20s
how'd it make you feel twenties you know
honestly it kind of made me sad
really
yeah because i was just like man you
know they don't like me for
[Laughter]
well you know you've done a number of
things in your life to put you
like in as like a contextual very high
status person like in the cheerleading
world if you're the number one guy and
you're doing all these impressive things
on stage like
men sometimes
underestimate the degree to which women
are attracted to competence you're
really good at something and you're the
best in the room like that's going to be
a big turn on right
um
and so there's all these situations
where like you know you're headlining a
stand-up show women are going to want to
[ __ ] you you're
like you just won a world championship
back flipping on stage women are gonna
want to [ __ ] you you're the coach and
you're really good at what you do women
you know what i mean it's always like
that just having everybody's laughing at
your jokes
exactly
yeah
no it makes sense but yeah no it did
used to make me sad because
you know because i am such a i i'm a
lover boy i i'm certified certified i'm
like i i drake i get your dog
wherever he's
because i know he listens but i like i'm
one fan that's just how i've always been
yeah you know so like whenever these you
know these situations would go down
where these
girls would want to sleep with me
situation
but like yeah like honestly yeah it kind
of made me [ __ ] feel sad because i
wasn't the guy that was like oh i need
to you know
go out right get it you know like well
let's go to the club this weekend design
your life it should sort of be
it shouldn't be a huge effort you
shouldn't let someone who's like you
shouldn't really be like no i think it's
awesome that christian like has the
balls to like he'll approach girls in
real life like i think most guys problem
is that they're scared to death
so you already have that figured out but
eventually you're going to set up your
life to where
it's women are going to funnel towards
you because
you're just the man you know what i mean
and it's easy but i think it is good to
like have these experiences where you're
just like shooting your shot going up to
any girl because it it just teaches you
so much and it removes that fear and
anxiety that most guys will go to the
grave having yeah approaching i think
it's more fun going off home it makes it
more fun yeah oh and if you have the
balls but also also lying out alone
listen the way he does it i don't think
it's [ __ ] weird he's he's literally
shooting his shoes and there's there's
literally nothing wrong with that like
making you know super uncomfortable yeah
i just went about it differently you
know what i mean it like that's how it
happened and they would say like girls
would say these things all the time like
you're such a mystery
yeah you know like and women love
mystery yeah you know
but also like there was so much to it
like one i never wanted to be
mean to girls basically because of the
way i saw my the way my mom was treated
yeah you know she she wasn't treated
good or anything so i nev so like when i
saw that i think that just kind of made
me go
you know just treat girls like better
than what
you know stepfather would treat yeah
women you know what i mean so that's
what you had that mentality
even when you were getting laid so it
wasn't a tactic in order to get laid
right like we were talking about before
where guys would be like flowers candy
like dates money and then [ __ ] you you
don't have sex with me
anyway
you're [ __ ] ugly like i mean i did
that when girls went
you know be my girlfriend
dude i would ask girls straight up like
just [ __ ] out of nowhere like you
wouldn't be you want to be my girlfriend
yeah yeah you're buying them victoria's
secret uh lotions and perfumes yeah i
did do that yeah
nobody like unless you have an older
dude who's good with women
it you're just stumbling through this
[ __ ] yeah kind of you're just making
those and every what guy hasn't thought
that it's like because you don't
understand what turns a woman on
especially as a kid and most adult men
don't so you're just like i look at you
and and can decide that i want to have
sex with you like look at me and and
decide if you want to have sex with me
or not like that's really what the
question is do you want to go on a date
with me you know it's like i sized you
up and like the way you look do you like
the way i look and it's just about
obviously more than that for such a
[ __ ] wild world but also like i mean
it's great but then you learn more about
it you know or you get i just think it's
great to be able to like
know and be more competent with you know
the opposite sex or the sex that you
want to
date because you just
you know
that's going to be a key to so much a
big part of your life relationships
yeah like you want to settle because you
didn't bother to
gain social skills and figure out how to
talk to women
yeah why
after all this talk about it yeah i
don't know just wait switching gears i
don't know oh cause i was gonna tell a
crazy sex story oh that's a
violent shifting gear so yeah
violence i just want this to be known
after the story you told us on fire in
the kid
everyone was commenting
asking if you knew that your brother
hooked you up with the prostitute for
your first time she wasn't a prostitute
i know i was just saying i thought it
was kind of funny
listen a couple people were yeah a
couple people thought that like it was
like a prostitute no she wasn't
are you sure though yeah why wouldn't i
be sure why wouldn't why wouldn't i just
say that now
could not know what
why wouldn't i just say it
right i feel like a pretty open book if
that happened
if that's what it is
also
first of all peel back 20 years of
therapy first of all
i know right
i want to see like how much i can go no
no no it's you know it's a fair question
but also at the same time
my brother would just [ __ ] tell me
yeah i i obviously like that he would
just be like yo i set you up he would
just say it i don't know would you do it
i don't know the context what happened
so it was the first time i ever had sex
right i was 21 years old
and uh which people think is weird but
hey it's mine
wait real quick before you get into this
21 if you don't mind
jesus christ this is second half type
[ __ ] yeah
i was super late i didn't get my first
kiss in my 20s
and then my friends that around me like
there was girls that that liked me and
they're super hot and other girls are
like what the [ __ ] he's not dating them
or whatever i'm like i was just like do
my thing whatever yeah so
my first kiss came from a girl that
uh
at a party who saw me with another girl
who had a crush on me but she was so
beautiful she was like she was so
attracted to me because i was like
whatever with this other girl yes and
then huge thing so then we made out like
at like 22 or 20 21 22.
so i didn't have sex i was like 23 or
24. i was way low in the game
wow because that's that was just my
personality 20. he said 20. mark
it's a 5.
what came out of the world
that little hercules that was him
a 15 okay so there's a five in there
were you in middle school when you were
[ __ ]
uh
like i'm trying to piece together
stories that i've heard from you before
uh when i lost my virginity i was a
sophomore in high school but i did all
this [ __ ] when i was in that's 14 before
uh no 15 15. dick suck when i was 14 and
the girl was like let's have sex and i
remember looking at the clock so that
should be another goal right now i'm
going to miss the bus the last bus home
so that's when i turned my 14 year old
virginity opportunity
you want to do that as a question now
yes so your first sexual experience like
it doesn't have to be sex
um like intercourse
oh go ahead i was gonna say probably at
my first communion
all right never mind no i i took it took
me a little bit oh got it okay i was
like okay what happened
no what actually is kind of funny i did
lose my virginity in a church parking
lot which i thought was kind of funny
and i'm not even making that seems very
on brand for you well so it was like a
middle of a snowstorm i walked two
blocks to the top of my neighborhood
because my neighborhood hadn't been
plowed yet she picked me up and then
drove me like a half mile down the road
to this church and then we that's where
i lost my virginity was it a black
church um no it was a greek orthodox
church there's not that many black
churches where i'm from so
i was as ethnic as we got
my first like the first time i've
not intercourse i don't know first time
i fingered a girl
uh it was on uh
we were coming from a cheer competition
it was on the one of those like
uh big buses
that like you see the football teams
yeah the coach buses we were coming from
uh and i remember the story clearly
because she was like sit by me sit by me
this girl you know flirted with me but
she literally had to like pull me to
like
actually sit by her or whatever i was
like okay i'll sit by you and then uh
you know we started you know she started
hugging me and i i got a boner when she
hugged no no she didn't hug me she just
like leaned to her head
i was like
and then uh
she like kind of you know she touched my
area and uh your area i know i know i'm
a modest guy
yeah and then i just
you know put my hand there started
fingering her or whatever and then uh
eventually stopped and literally
literally
literally i know you're still doing it
to this day
i get weird telling sex stories or
anything like that
literally did not wash my hands until i
got home because i wanted to know did
you like take your hands out just go
like this
but yeah i rolled up from from long
beach back to phoenix arizona i did not
wash my hand just so i know when i got
home and i didn't want to smell it in
front of her just in case of a smell bad
and i was like oh you know what i mean i
don't want to do that you're curious
yeah i was curious and i [ __ ] kept
that [ __ ] strong held onto it like this
as soon as i got off that bus and got
home i was like that's called trigger
let me see what's going on right here
what'd you say work because it's called
triggered and that girl was also my
first kiss oh
i do have a picture with her but i but i
just would rather it be blurred out
third half
third half is it on your eyes i don't
want to show her
no no
if that's okay i'll show the picture of
her i just don't want to i just want it
blurred
we got to get that on your computer but
yeah i just have to add it in post and
yes i just want to add it i don't like
putting people's business out there
especially because like they're not part
of this world and yeah i feel weird
telling stories now about people who
aren't in this world yeah so i keep a
lot back because i learned very quickly
where do you want me to send it to you
it's anime so while you're on your phone
uh air drop it to my laptop so while
he's finding that what's your airdrop i
have it
what's your airdrop this is my
christian's laptop it should no i just
see chris i just saw your phone you guys
just texted me i was a little fiend from
a very young age i was very like
sexually aware and i think it has a lot
to do with
trauma that i had as a child not sexual
trauma but like i got my ass beat a lot
and i'm unpacking in therapy but i was a
very sexual child from a very young age
and so this was a long time coming where
my parents went away to vietnam for
something i think it was a funeral they
were gone for about a month and my aunt
stayed with us my parents were very
strict they had alarms where if you open
the door a window the alarm would say
like window in room one open window and
room one closed i remember that one
and so like i was not allowed in and out
of the house without someone hearing
like hey someone has left the premises
and when this happened my aunt knew how
the alarm system worked to extend she
knew how to turn it on and turn it off
and i looked up online how to
basically turn off the sound of like
this door is open so it'll alert it if
you look at the home board and you see
the different doors if the light is off
then it says like oh okay the door is
open so i found out if you put a magnet
onto that you can leave something open
and it'll still think it's closed so i
snuck my then boyfriend in that way
through the window and for like two
weeks there's nothing but like
fingering and like mad dry humping very
aggressive dry humping for like two
weeks and my parents are gonna come home
the following week and we just made this
plan like okay
we're gonna have sex he had already had
sex before me and i was losing my
virginity trying to play it cool i was
so [ __ ] nervous i was so scared one
night he came over we try to have sex
and i swear to god my nerves were so bad
i couldn't like get comfortable and so
everything was so [ __ ] painful i felt
like someone was shoving a flashlight up
there
so we stopped and then the next day he
came over and we tried again and i just
remember like
being like a plank just like is it over
is it over is it over this hurts this
horse he had a hog on him huh that's
another thing yes he did and i didn't
know because i i was always her like
flashlight
i was always under the assumption that's
truly what it felt like uh that asian
men had smaller dicks from that
stereotype and i hadn't had any sexual
experience prior to these two weeks
leading up to me losing my virginity so
i thought like his dick was at the very
least a average-sized dick yeah i was
like this can't be small but at the same
time like maybe this is what average is
the first one and that and we end up
having sex and everything was pretty
normal after that but it was until he
and i had broken up like nine years
later when i had my first like sexual
experience afterwards the guy
wasn't like he didn't have a small dick
but he definitely didn't have a big dick
either and that's when i learned my ex
had a huge dick
because the next guy was like wait a
minute yeah without that's where you
searched until you found stevie
chasing the dragon you ever seen
her she showed it to us on uh i mean
i've seen the clips of you guys looking
at it um i know chris is knowing
something he doesn't surprise me this is
me have any of you guys seen marx i've
been terrified ever since
that was my first kiss
oh you're a kid oh yeah so cute i think
i was like
i'm rocking that thrasher i was like a
wholesome
15 right there you like the white woman
don't you she's not white
latina
you just think the white race is the
[ __ ]
dominant baby
people are going to start asking where
it was january 6 and she's just not
going to be good she's cute no yeah yeah
she was really cute i was yeah i was
nervous about that first kiss i didn't
know how to do it it was so awkward well
you don't know how to do it you used to
practice on like no no
i was too scared to practice
did you yeah when i was really young
when i was about like
seven from seven to nine i always i'd
have my first kiss
like around middle school so i was like
i need a prep for this moment so i used
to try to like make out with the back of
my hand because i had a cousin who used
to do that and then i was just like this
is [ __ ] stupid yeah so there's like
no way this feels like a lip wait was
your first kiss five
oh no uh like kiss on the lips like
seventh grade but then i didn't french
kiss
kisses i know this is what they used to
say mac yeah oh did you guys mac yeah
nothing about life
so my first girlfriend in high school
were that i french kissed with
finger got a [ __ ] like wanted me to
have sex before i had to leave on the
bus uh she was a vietnamese girl named
win oh
that's super asian oh special place in
your heart yeah yeah seriously when was
yours
man pre-puberty i was pimping
i kissed a fifth grader in fourth grade
i got i got tongue in seventh grade i
figured a girl in the girls locker room
in eighth grade and then [ __ ]
started growing and i was just left
behind
me too
fourth grade and then actually like
going back to what you say just like the
confidence and like i don't know you're
i wasn't chasing [ __ ] but i was just
not confident enough to go after it so
it was just kind of dormant until i
started finding like my yeah yeah so
what you you just like
when you didn't have any confidence you
just didn't [ __ ] you didn't make any
type of move yeah it'd be like like if
you're out at parties then there'd be
like drunken makeouts but like in terms
of like pursuing a girl just regularly
yeah yeah i was like what would i really
have to offer at this point
listen my first kiss could have happened
at 15 but it didn't have until i was
like 16 or 17.
we were we uh
i was with uh two two homies of mine it
was
three dudes three girls and we we
went to this girl's house it was like
late on a saturday night their parents
were like sleeping and [ __ ] and we were
in the garage like hanging out and we
started doing that that truth or dare
[ __ ] and
one uh one girl dared me to make out
with another girl and i [ __ ] said no
i said no and my excuse was i was like
oh
i can't do it because i don't know who
you are
that was my [ __ ] excuse but like i
could have done it but that's just like
when i think about like the the com but
it was a confidence thing you know what
i mean like because it's like
one i've never made out two i'm about to
make out in front of people you know
what i mean so it was just like a
[ __ ]
stressful [ __ ] situation at 15 years
old yeah you know what i mean so i feel
you we're like the same dude yeah a lot
of ways we are we've you know remembered
that on the old episodes of cats after
that yeah we yeah we're like the same
[ __ ] dude meanwhile bart got a hog
couple different
what did you say i said there's a couple
of differences between you and me just a
few
what are they what about you chin i
don't know what was your sex story
same thing the first time you like
fooled around anything no that was my
first my first kiss because i was i
started late so that girl that was like
20 right same night huh 20
early 20s early 20s yeah i'm not sure
exactly when but so that's my first kiss
was the first time i actually
licked tits
hey
so i'm like i just tried everything at
that moment i was like all right so i'm
gonna we're gonna say
fingering i was doing everything she's
like huh we should take it so i'm like
all right cool and then it was dry
humping it was like all crazy hey that
drives really so my first place
everything other than at least you
checked everything off in the same night
but no no there's no dick sucker or
anything like that yeah
oh you getting your dicks off and by the
way this was in a group
this is this back in the days when we
were like partying with friends at our
house
our friends are sleeping around us
everyone's yeah
and we're doing this around them yeah
and then of course the next morning
they're like
our friends are like dude we heard
everything that was just oh i heard
everybody i'm like oh [ __ ]
you think you're being sneaky yeah
because you said i was just [ __ ]
at that moment
where are y'all sexy as [ __ ] bro y'all
need to calm down
i don't know if i'd say we're all sexy
yeah it's interesting that you guys i
like how you look to me chappelle that's
so young i've had a lot of people at my
school loser virginia oh virginity yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah i was it was pretty
[ __ ] it was pretty it was pretty i
think i got along
i think i got all these what do you say
when i was like
how old are you in seventh grade twelve
twelve or three years was your first
experience first four years early dude i
said 12 year olds who were [ __ ] were
trash pretty much yeah yeah
like in my i went to catholic school so
a very different uh opinion but we hung
out with public school kids we heard
about those narrative wells dirty dudes
yeah well and honestly it kind of played
out though i mean can i tell you about
stevie's first time because it shocked
me
oh yes
you was it in jail yeah you actually
lost a virginity to me it's crazy no he
was uh he told me that he was 10 years
old and he had uh met this girl who went
to the high school so she was 14. and
this girl found out that he had a big
dick at this time he didn't realize that
he had a big dick because he says his
dick has been the same size since he was
10. he had that adult dick yeah
and so this one girl like had sex with
him as he was when he was like basically
in elementary school and he's just like
oh this is [ __ ] cool and she told all
her friends and now her and her friends
are like sharing him like passing him
around and he just thought he was the
[ __ ] man he was yeah yeah he was yeah
oh yeah he was kevin he's probably
starting to jerk off around then so yeah
like oh a bunch of [ __ ] older hot
girls all want to [ __ ] ride your dick
like what yeah and he ended up getting
held back in school for like a year or
two so when he was in middle school he
was already driving
and he would have uh these girls like
fighting over him because they were like
best friend cheerleaders like you said
what stevie and they would get in these
huge fights and then he'd go pick up
like his current girlfriend while the
other one like cried it was like you're
[ __ ] trash but also those women need
to be in prison yeah yeah you were dead
i mean no it makes sense because like
just knowing stevie and also he's like
to me obviously you know a lot better he
like he doesn't seem flashy at all
obviously yeah and he is i would say he
seems like a true introvert right yeah
he's but he's very confident and like
his manner with women is confident so
all that like it just plays into it
doesn't really matter if you're shy or
not but obviously he has like experience
and confidence with women and yeah pick
up on that and and it's just
you know that's an attractive thing
right but to be fair god is fair and
gave him cancer but he survived
[Laughter]
you're gonna [ __ ] 20 girls by the time
you're 11. your 10 was great for you but
17 is going to be right yeah i gotta i
got to give you cancer oh yeah you'll
let it be okay yeah you'll live your
life most kids said you'd probably be
like all right i'll take it yeah
i'll gladly die of cancer at
oh my god hey you reckless dog it is
weird talking to someone in their
[ __ ] early twenties and just hearing
how [ __ ] like yeah i [ __ ] i don't
play you know what i mean you're past
27. what'd you say what nothing
yeah i was just making a joke i said i
don't plan on being here past 27 anyway
you [ __ ] weirdo kids you said didn't
you say something like i'm here for a
good time not a long time
[Laughter]
i know i
way
up i feel blessed that's what it is oh
you know that hot sauce thing is
apparently fake
is it yeah there was an article
by how well the article was written
it's away
you proceeded to suck on her titties for
three minutes before going to the magnum
condom drawer and taking out a large
cotton because drake has a large penis
no she said he had like a seven inch
dick and he was circumcised i guess
somebody from his like i've
heard several other women say that
he's not circumcised well not i don't
know
i just heard like even seven oh my god
he gives off big dick energy i will say
there's a call
about him that i think he has a big dick
look up drake penis size oh damn
google doesn't want to look it up
images ooh i know what the hell
yeah i kind of already regret that
view
views drake
christian's computer has never heard of
safe search
[Laughter]
oh this is my incognito in high school
it's non-existent my high school that i
grew up going to this is like i'm logged
into my high school email because i
still use it they can track everything i
look up so for the past five years
they've definitely seen some wild [ __ ]
they're like christian get a new email
jesus christ
yeah it's not great you made it
oh wow
tune in next week to hear about the
second time we all had sex
[Music]
oh yeah i'm gonna edit this and uh
upload it and show it to brandon uh yeah
see we thinks and then
yeah i don't know we'll find a day that
makes sense yeah sure there's like uh
fridays you know does anything drop on
friday no no but i mean just people
no uh not for recording in terms of like
the things like a podcast david david
show jobs fridays
don't you drop fridays mines does uh
tuesdays right yeah tuesdays if they're
watching this they already know what day
it drops yeah if you're watching yeah
yeah
and we got more sex stories
you know i know you guys are getting all
riled up probably touching yourselves
listening to this i got some adult sex
stories for you
and uh to reiterate if you want to
participate in the show in any way send
logos and musics and intros whatever
topic ideas we'll do interactive [ __ ] we
used to zoom with people
we just play games only super cast
people too i should have said that on
the free episode but
uh yeah so enjoy boom bye
[Music]
you